the once red-hot housing market is
showing signs of cooling off according
to data from realtor.com the median home
price fell three percent in august to
435 thousand dollars however that is
still up 14
from august of 2021 keeping prices high
not enough new homes and a shortage of
workers to build them to keep up with
demand the construction industry will
need more than 2 million more workers by
2024 and as we learned more and more
women are stepping up
can you help me out
thank you
after about 10 years as a new york city
barista
desiree camacho decided it was time to
nail down a new path construction even
my own mom when i told her i was
interested in doing this she's like why
would you want to do that that's a man's
job and i was just like yeah well i need
the man's money so i'm going to go do
the man's work i guess
and it historically has been a man's job
but more women like camacho are signing
up what do you like about this job as it
is it can all be very different like one
day you're running pipe the next day
you're like splicing wires so there's
always something new and exciting to
learn every day now an apprentice
camacho enrolled in trade school after
spotting an ad on the subway and for
those starting or switching careers
there's been a big payoff the industry
boasts one of the country's narrowest
pay gaps with female construction
workers earning about 95 percent of a
male worker's median pay and jobs that
often don't require a college degree and
as the number of women in construction
has increased more than 50 percent in a
decade to more than a million it's in
part because of recruitment campaigns
like this one one of our big values is
legacy would you call women in untapped
market it's absolutely not tap market we
are fighting workforce shortages with
one hand tied behind our back brian
tremail is with the associated general
contractors of america which launched a
digital outreach urging women to
consider construction jobs attracting
tens of thousands of applicants and
everything from the basics like take the
darn pinup calendar off the trailer wall
to more fundamental changes in thinking
about how do we create an environment
that's more welcoming how do we listen
to new people
in the carolinas salmon corporation
started offering paid parental leave
women now make up nearly 20 percent of
its workforce
the next generation already building a
new phase of construction do you think
women could be the answer to the labor
shortage absolutely i mean we're people
we have hands we have brains that work
we're here
we're strong we can do the work also and
like we have been showing up to do it
yes they have and don't you love that if
you want a man's pay that's right the
man's job yeah and you that's like
apple's apples comparison and still 95
of what a man earns
usually it's about 70 to 85 cents on the
dollar of what a man earns
all right thanks nancy